من جهته افاد مراسلنا باستشهاد فلسطيني
واصابه اخرين في قصف اسرائيلي على منزل
لعائله ضهير في رفح جنوبي قطاع غزه كما
قصفت قوات الاحتلال مناطق مختلفه من خان
يونس خاصه منطقه بني سهيله وتتعرض جباليا
البلد ومخيم جباليا الى قصف مدفعي
اسرائيلي كثيف وغارات جويه وتحاول اليات
الاحتلال التقدم من الجهه الغربيه لجبال
حيث تدو اشتباكات واطلاق
نار معنا من مستشفى شهداء الاقصى في دير
البلح مراسل الجزيره هشام زقوت ك معك هشام
والمشهد في غزه هذا
الصباح المشهد هو قصف اسرائيلي متواصل في
اكثر من منطقه واكثر من محافظه في قطاع
غزه وربما شمل القصف من بيت حنون شمالا
الى رفح جنوبا حيث ممر القصف الاسرائيلي
لا يختلف صباح هذا اليوم عن صباحات جميع
ايام الحرب الاسرائيليه لا سما وان القصف
مستمر القصف من الطائرات الحربيه
الاسرائيليه القصف من المدفعيه
الاسرائيليه وايضا حتى الزوارق الحربيه
الاسرائيليه قصفت السواحل الغربيه لقطاع
غزه او محافظات مختلفه من قطاع غزه في رفح
جنوبا قصفت الطائرات الحربيه الاسرائيليه
عده منازل دمرتها وسوتها بالارض ايضا شقق
سكنيه تعرضت للاستهداف في اكثر من منطقه
في م مدينه رفح جنوب قطاع غزه وعندما
نتحدث عن مدينه رفح نحن نتحدث عن المنطقه
التي طلب الجيش الاسرائيلي من سكان مدينه
خانيونس ان يتوجهوا اليها ورغم كل ذلك
لاحقهم القصف الاسرائيلي الى رفح دمر هذه
المنازل سواها بالارض وقتل
واصاب العديد من الفلسطينيين اذا هذه
المنطقه تتعرض الى قصف منذ عده ايام الى
قصف يستهدف منازل مدنيه فلسطينيه وهذه
المنازل وهذه مدينه رفح باتت مكتظه بشكل
كبير بسبب هذا الطلب من الجيش الاسرائيلي
لمدينه خانيونس ان يتوجهوا الى رفح
وبالتالي المنازل مكتظه بالعائلات
الفلسطينيه وايضا بالنازحين الذين لجوا
الى منازل اقاربهم الى منازل جيرانهم
بحاله من التكافل والتضامن ولكن رغم كل
ذلك يقصف الجيش الاسرائيلي ويكثف من
غاراته في رفح جنوب قطاع غزه لكن ايضا
القصف مستمر ومتواصل في مدينه خانيونس
كذلك مدينه غرب مدينه خانيونس تعرضت عده
منازل ايضا للقصف من الطائرات الحربيه
الاسرائيليه ودمرت الطائرات هذه المنازل
ايضا المناطق الشرقيه هي المسرح الابرز
لهذه الاحداث ولهذا القصف الاسرائيلي قصف
من المدفعيه الاسرائيليه قصف من الطائرات
الحربيه الاسرائيليه في بني سيلا في خزاعه
في القراره في عبسان وهذه المناطق تتعرض
الى قصف عنيف منذ عده اسابيع من الطائرات
الحربيه الاسرائيليه ربما لا يكاد يخلو
منزل في هذه المناطق من قصف اسرائيلي من
دمار بسبب هذا هذا القصف من المدفعيه
وايضا من الطائرات الحربيه حتى هذه
المناطق باتت معزوله عن جميع مناطق قطاع
غزه لاسما وان الجيش الاسرائيلي يحاصرها
من الشرق ومن الغرب وبالتالي يمنع سيارات
الاسعاف وسيارات الدفاع المدني من الوصول
اليها ومنذ عده اسابيع لم تستطع سيارات
الاسعاف من الوصول الى هذه المناطق
الشرقيه لخان يونس وبالتالي لم تنتشل اي
من الجثامين ولم يخلى اي من الجرحى من هذه
المناطق وبالتالي من يصاب في تلك المناطق
يبقى على الارض مصابا ينزف حتى الموت ولا
تسمح قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي لسيارات
الاسعاف بالوصول اليه ايضا في وسط القطاع
كانت منطقه حكر الجامع في دير البلح وسط
قطاع غزه مسرحا لقصف اسرائيلي عنيف
وبالتالي دمر مربع سكني من جراء هذا القصف
الاسرائيلي ونقل عدد من الشهداء والجرحى
الى مستشفى شهداء الاقصى جراء هذا القصف
العنيف لمنطقه الحكر في دير البلح ودير
البلح تتعرض الى قصف عنيف منذ عده ايام من
الطائرات الحربيه الاسرائيليه وتستهدف
منازل مدنيه فلسطينيه وتدمرها وتسويها
بالارض وعندما نتحدث عن منازل نحن نتحدث
ان جميع منازل دير البلح وكافه محافظات
قطاع غزه فيها نازحون فلسطينيون تكتظ
بالسكان الذين هربوا من شمال قطاع غزه من
مدينه غزه من المناطق الشرقيه لقطاع غزه
ولا جاوا الى قلب المدن ولكن يلاحقهم
القصف الاسرائيلي ويقتلهم ويشرم من جديد
وهناك العشرات من العائلات نزحت بدل المره
يمكن ان نقول خمس مرات على الاقل نزحت من
منزل الى منزل جراء الدمار الكبير الذي
تحدثه الغارات الاسرائيليه والتي تلاحق
هذه العائلات الفلسطينيه في المنازل التي
يحلون فيها ضيوفا ولكن رغم كل ذلك القصف
مستمر القصف ايضا مستمر في مخيم النصيرات
في وسط قطاع غزه وهذا المخيم يشهد منذ عده
ايام قصف من المدفعيه الاسرائيليه لا سما
المناطق الشمال ماليه لمخيم النصيرات
منطقه ارض المفتي وايضا منطقه المغرا
منطقه مدينه الزهراء وهذه المناطق تتعرض
الى قصف عنيف من المدفعيه الاسرائيليه منذ
عده ايام وشهدت وشهد مخيم النصيرات عده
غارات استهدفت منازل مدنيه فلسطينيه منزل
في مخيم في المخيم الجديد في مخيم
النصيرات ايضا في مخيم اثنين تعرضت شقه
سكنيه ومنزل كذلك الى قصف من الطائرات
الحربيه الاسرائيليه ونقل عدد من الشهداء
الى مستشفى شهداء الاقصى وايضا الى مستشفى
العوده في مخيم النصيرات الذي بات يستقبل
العديد من المصابين والشهداء جراء
الاستهدافات الاسرائيليه في مخيم النصيرات
كذلك مخيم البريج تعرض الى قصف عنيف من
المدفعيه لا سما المناطق الشرقيه للمخيم
وكذلك منزل دمر وسوي بالارض على رؤوس
السكان في مخيم البريج ونقل عدد من
الشهداء والجرحى في مدينه غزه وشمال
القطاع ربما يكون القصف اكثر عنفا واكثر
كثافه لاسما وان القصف يتركز في الاحياء
الشرقيه لمدينه غزه في حي الشجاعيه وايضا
في حي التفاح حيث دمرت الطائرات الحربيه
الاسرائيليه عده منازل في هذه الاحياء
ايضا حي الشيخ رضوان كان مسرحا الليله
الماضيه لقصف عنيف من المدفعيه
الاسرائيليه تعمل القوات الاسرائيليه على
اعاده التمركز والتموضع في اكثر من منطقه
في حي الشيخ رضوان قصفت عده منازل
المدفعيه الاسرائيليه والاليات العسكريه
الاسرائيليه ايضا يسمع اصوات انفجارات
واصوات اشتباكات ناجمه عن اشتباك على ما
يبدو عناصر المقاومه الفلسطينيه مع قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي التي تحركت وتحركت من
اماكنها وعادت التموضع في مناطق مختلفه من
حي الشيخ رضوان وعلى اطرافه وباتت تقصف
المنازل المدنيه الفلسطينيه بالقذائف حي
الشجاعيه ايضا مازال محاصرا تمنع قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي الدخول او الخروج من
هذا الحي لا سما وان هذا الحي يتعرض منذ
عده ايام الى قصف عنيف من المدفعيه من
الطائرات الحربيه الاسرائيليه نشاهد الصور
وكان زلزالا حل بحي الشجاعيه لم يبقى فيه
منزلا قائما على اركانه وبالتالي القصف
مستمر ومتواصل على هذا الحي في كل لحظه
وفي كل حين ومن ايضا يستشهد ويصاب في حي
الشجاعيه يبقى على الارض مصابا ينزف حتى
الموت لا ي لا تستطيع طواقم الدفاع المدني
ولا طواقم الاسعاف الوصول اليه او انتشاله
او اجلاء في شمال قطاع غزه القصف باث بات
اكثر عنفا وكان الجيش الاسرائيلي يحاول
تخليص عمليه ما بمعنى ان الجيش الاسرائيلي
يكثف غاراته على بلده جباليا على مخيم
جباليا على بيت حنون وبيت لاهيه لكن
المسرح الابرز والاكثر كثافه للنيران هما
في مخيم جباليا وبلده جباليا وهما يتعرضان
الى قصف عنيف يستهدف منازل مدنيه فلسطينيه
لم يبقى منزل في مخيم جباليا وبلده جباليا
لم يطاله القصف الاسرائيلي وحتى المنازل
التي لجا اليها الناس الناس باتت محاصره
في جباليا ويلج جا الناس الى منازل
اقاربهم الى جيرانهم وبالتالي المنازل
باتت مكتظه بشكل كبير هناك مئات ان السكان
يتواجدون في منزل واحد ولكن رغم كل ذلك
يقصف الجيش الاسرائيلي يدمر هذه المنازل
على رؤوس السكان ويقتل عائلات فلسطينيه
باكملها ومن بين المصابين كان الدكتور
منير البرش مدير عام وزاره الصحه
الفلسطينيه وعائلته التي اصيب عدد من
افرادها واستشهدت ابنته جنى وبالتالي
القصف الاسرائيلي بات اكثر عنفا وكانه
محاوله لانتقام الجيش الاسرائيلي من
السكان الذين ما زالوا مصرين على البقاء
في جباليا ويصرون على عدم ترك منازلهم
والخروج منها